Speaker 1: I want to start today with something
that many of us at this point intuitively
probably understand and something that's also
been made explicit by the FBI and other law
enforcement agencies over the last year or
two, which is that at this point in time for
the United States, without saying anything
about time's past necessarily right now, the
U.S. is facing as way more domestic terror
threats, as foreign terror threats.
There's a very interesting Newsweek article
about this which says the U.S. is facing far
more domestic terror threats than those from
international parties, according to the FBI.
Timothy Langan, assistant director of the
bureau's counterterrorism division, told lawmakers
Wednesday that the U.S. is approaching more
than 2700 domestic terrorism threats.
The number of international terror threats
is under 1000.
Langen also gave statistics on terrorism related
deaths in the U.S. from 2015 to 2020.
There were 80 reported international terrorism
related deaths, compared with 83 deaths linked
to domestic terrorism.
Langan's testimony follows FBI Director Christopher
Wray statements to Congress earlier this month
when he said the number of domestic terrorism
cases has exploded in the last year and a
half.
A recent AP poll found more Americans are
concerned about threats from extremist groups
based on based in the U.S. as opposed to those
from other countries.
Sixty five percent of U.S. adults report being
extremely or very concerned about domestic
group threats, compared with 50 percent feeling
the same about foreign extremist groups.
We there's a couple things here.
One is it's really common that people's fear
of things is often out of line with the actual
danger of that thing.
We see this with vaccine stuff, right?
There are lots of people who are afraid of
covid, but this movement of people afraid
of the vaccine when really it's covid you
should be much more afraid of.
That would be one example.
In general, people tend to worry much more
about, for example, being the victims of a
terrorist attack, despite it being an insanely
unlikely that any of us would ever be.
Doesn't mean some people won't be, but statistically
speaking, insanely unlikely versus things
we don't think much about, like getting in
a car every day, which is actually a comparatively
dangerous thing given the number of people
who die yearly from terrorism in the US versus
the number who die in car accidents or being
more afraid of flying than driving in a car,
even though the driving in a car is far more
dangerous.
OK, so so that's one thing that oftentimes,
even though the domestic terror threat is
a bigger threat, people think of the idea
of often it's dangerous Muslims from the Middle
East or sometimes it would be brown immigrants
from Latin America or whatever the trope of
the week, month or year happens to be.
But then, number two, you know, there are
entire media apparatuses in the United States
that are very similar to what we see in other
countries, radicalize people into what is
often referred to in the U.S. as a jihadist
terror or Islamic or Islamist terror.
We have the equivalent in the United States
of these media outlets that spread hate and
so fear and radicalize people.
And many Americans don't recognize them as
being the sort of domestic equivalents of
the stuff that we say, well, how did these
people, these people end up getting radicalized
in the ISIS, for example?
And you look at the media and the Internet
content, but then we wonder, how did so many
people end up getting radicalized to the point
where they rioted on January 6th or they put
pipe bombs in Washington, D.C. or whatever
the case may be?
And then you look at what we have happening
on Facebook and on Newsmax to some degree,
a Fox News and Alex Jones and so many others.
This stuff radicalizes people as well.
And it should come as no surprise that when
the rubber hits the road, the domestic terror
is actually far more of a threat mathematically
than the foreign terror.
And yet another report from the FBI confirms
exactly that.
Now, if you think that although the number
may be greater, it makes sense because, well,
you're in the U.S., so the Americans are already
here.
That doesn't mean that they are more dangerous.
On average.
There may be more of them.
And, you know, if it's eighty three versus
eighty deaths from terror, the fact that there
are more threats doesn't mean.
That much, I would disagree, the fact that
there are that many potential nodes of radicalism
and terrorism domestically means that there's
way more people who could be activated, could
be activated by the exact type of rhetoric
that we've been fighting against.
Let me know your thoughts